hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we are going to look at the
Builder of one of the most recognized
companies of all time ray Croft from
McDonald's Raymond Albert Kroc was a
Czech American businessman who took over
the small-scale McDonald's Corporation
franchise in 1954 and built it into the
most successful fast-food operation in
the world Kroc was included in time 100
the most important people of the century
and amassed a 500 million dollar fortune
during his lifetime he was also the
owner of the San Diego Padres baseball
team started in 1974
Ray Kroc began his career selling paper
cups for the Lille tulip cup it was in
the course of selling paper cups that
crock would meet oral prints crock had
noticed prints after he began buying
lily cups by the truckload for product
that he had recently invented a 5
spindle milkshake mixer crock saw big
opportunities in the milkshake mixer and
bought the exclusive marketing rights to
the product over the next 17 years crock
would travel across America selling it
when he receives an order for eight
milkshake mixers from brothers dick and
Mac McDonald in California he had to go
out to see them the McDonald brothers
had focused on just a few menu items
hamburgers cheeseburgers french fries
soft drinks and milkshakes Kroc was
impressed with the efficiency and the
popularity of the restaurant and saw his
next business opportunity with them in
one of the greatest success stories of
all time Kroc took a small but
successful california-based hamburger
restaurant and expanded it into what
today is a worldwide chain of 400,000
employees 22 billion dollars in revenue
and a logo that has come to become
globally recognized more than the
Christian cross so the next question
becomes how can you model the success of
Ray Kroc here are three action items
that you can put to use in your business
today action item number one always be
on the lookout for opportunities most
entrepreneurs don't end up being
successful with the product or service
that they start with there are always
tweaks and changes that will happen once
you start talking to customers
they tell you what they want your
prospects and customers will lead you to
many potential opportunities to grow
your business the key is to jump on
those opportunities and take action in
ray crocks own words the two most
important requirements for major success
are first being in the right place at
the right time and second doing
something about it
Kroc started out as a salesman for paper
cups and his customers twice brought him
to new business opportunities that he
acted on sometimes this can mean selling
a completely different product or
service and your offering before look at
your current customers are there hidden
business opportunities you can develop
with them or improvements to what you're
currently selling that can bring more
value to them and put more money in your
bank account if you're always going to
look out for new opportunities to grow
your business you'll eventually find the
one you can hit a home run with
action item number two you're only as
good as the people you hire as your
business grows beyond yourself you
realize the importance of having a good
team they are the ones representing your
company making decisions every day and
talking to your customers having a good
staff will make or break your ability to
build a successful company beyond
yourself to make sure he had the best
team possible in the early stages of the
business
Ray Kroc personally took charge of the
entire hiring process once he had made
the decision to bring someone on board
the McDonald's team Kwok wicked each and
every one of them a badge with the title
of Management Trainee
it didn't matter what their actual job
was Kroc wanted every employee to feel
valuable and like an important part of
his team Kroc would then tell his
workers to think of better ways to do
their job or any improvements that could
in his in customer service which could
then be written down and placed into a
suggestion box the suggestion box led to
countless successes like the Happy Meal
filet-o-fish Big Mac hot apple pie and
Egg McMuffin when you hire a new
employee make them feel like they're
important part of your team encourage
their suggestions on how the business
could be run better create opportunities
for them to advance and let them know
that you value their contributions a
loyal and hardworking team will reward
you with outstanding business results
action item number three be a part of
your community whatever community you
sell to make sure you take part in
building that community base and making
it stronger these are the people who
continue to buy from you and the more
successful they are the more successful
you will be
Ray Kroc launched a number of
initiatives to help build the
communities around each McDonald's
restaurant first off he insisted that
his franchise operators lived in the
communities where they worked he also
hired regional advertising agencies so
they could work on the ground and
organize grand openings birthday parties
and community programs
finally he believed in community
involvement through charities and the
company continues to give back to this
day as part of its corporate philosophy
you don't have to run a restaurant to be
involved in your community just think
about the people you sell to and where
they hang out how can you get involved
in making their lives easier and better
it's a longer term strategy but
extremely profitable if you can win the
hearts and minds of your
stammers by giving back so remember
always be on the lookout for
opportunities you're only as good as the
people you hire and be a part of your
community to finish off the video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories about Ray Kroc when Kroc was
just four years old his father took him
to a phrenologist to try to have his
future determined based on the shape of
his head
here the young Kroc was told that he
would be best suited to having a career
in the fast food industry nearly 50
years later he would fulfill the
prediction thank you for joining me for
another edition of modeling the masters
I hope you enjoy I'd love to hear your
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below and stay tuned to the next episode